what they're talking about it's not
their proof but it comes from Norway the
Norwegian seismic organization called
Nosa they have a monitoring station in
Romania which is 400 miles away from the
novakovka dam and they say that they
picked up at exactly the time explosions
were heard they picked up a seismic
disturbance 400 miles away which could
only have come from huge explosions they
pinned it down to exactly where the dam
was they've pinned down the size of the
explosions you can see on the graph that
they've published and this has come from
Norway now this convinces the ukrainians
and the rest of us that a major
explosion series of explosions took
place then because you can only breach a
dam like that with big explosions
literally tons of explosives placed at
the very base of the dam that's almost
certainly is what happened and the
ukrainians would never be in a position
to do that they didn't own that part of
the dam the Russians are in control of
it so and they we knew that they'd mind
it last October we were waiting for them
to do this and I'm 99 certain it was
them and of course the reason that they
would try and blow up that down if it
was the Russians uh well because it then
made it very difficult for the
ukrainians to attack across the NEPA
River uh it creates another humanitarian
problem for Ukraine distracts them while
they're trying to conduct this
counter-offensive and there's a degree
of Revenge in it as well I think if
you're going to attack us but we'll blow
the dam up I mean they've been thinking
about it for a long time we're sure
about that and now they've done it so
the ukrainians feel they have proof that
it was the Russians who blew up the dam
meanwhile the Kremlin is furious about a
drone attack that they say uh was the
ukrainians on Russian territory yeah uh
verones which is a town it's over 100
miles away from the Ukrainian border so
it's deep inside Russia
um a drone attack today the Taft news
agency the Russian news agency said it
was two drones which is entirely logical
because they're normally sent in twos or
more and they say it was a a targeting a
military facility which is interesting
they normally would say targeted
residential area to make ukrainians uh
look uh fairly bad it said military
facility we don't know what that was but
given that this was so deep inside
Russia I think it's the ukrainians
occasion that they're taking the gloves
off they don't care now they want to
bring home to the Russian people that if
you invade your neighbor there will be
consequences you can't pretend this
isn't to do with you I think that's the
message they're sending but it's a
dangerous message I think you know Kiev
is playing with fire doing this in terms
of upsetting their Western backers who
don't like to see this sort of thing no
I wonder if also part of that is to do
with the early stages of the spring
offensive that we're seeing this change
of of dynamic from the ukrainians where
where are we seeing this uh this
beginning of this yeah for sure I mean
all of this all this these attacks
inside Russia will get lost in the
general drama of the offensive this is
another reason why the offensive has
started and so we know now that it's
it's taking place in three areas we can
identify three Focus although folk live
attack one is around back much north and
south of bakmut uh the parakeviefker
just north of baked even if not not the
town itself but either side of it the
ukrainians are pushing quite hard and
we'll see how that that goes but then
the other two further south are much
more interesting and important in a way
valika novasilka which is quite near to
vuladar which has been contested for
some months now there's a push going on
there but the most interesting is in
Oregon further west a big battle has
been going on there started a couple of
days ago we know that a lot of equipment
has been using we know that the
ukrainians have lost material the 47th
mechanized Brigade has lost some Western
tanks there that's inevitable we've seen
that so the 47th of Fike in there and
the big battle going over give as if the
ukrainians were trying to push the top
Mac which is where the Russians have got
very stiff defenses and if they get to
talk to top map they might try to push
to Malita pole all the way down to the
coast in terms of strategic objectives I
call this route one if they are prepared
to take Route 1 if they think they're
strong enough to do it taking on the
best of the Russian defenses and push
right down to the coast then they
achieve the Strategic objective of
splitting the land bridge in half
splitting Russian forces in half
isolating all the all the Russian forces
to the west of that line and critically
putting Crimea in Peril they can then
bombard Crimea if they get to the coast
of the Sea of azov so it's the most it's
the most ambitious and dangerous thing
they can try we don't yet know if
they're really going for that but
they're pushing hard at you they've made
the Russians commit resources and
reserves which is probably what they
wanted to do then they can have a good
look at them if they can get the
opposition to turn everything on then
they have a good look at what's there so
this may not be the main thrust but
they're certainly convincing the
Russians that they're serious about
oricu because they themselves are
fighting a fierce battle there so that's
the one that I'm looking at with most
interest but there are three places now
where this offensive is pushing hard and
we'll see I think I mean Kiev may not
yet know quite where it's going to
finish up it's it's assessing the
situation and so they may see how the
Russians react before they decide where
they'll really put their money